we're told that eric is shorter than
preethi preethi is 158 centimeters tall
write an inequality that compares eric's
height in centimeters e
to prethese height pause this video and
see if you can do that
all right so we have eric's height which
we are using the variable capital e4 and
how does it compare it says eric is
shorter than preethi
so eric's height is going to be less
than whatever preethi's height is which
is
158 centimeters
you could think about it on a number
line too if i were to draw a number line
like this
and this is
158 centimeters preethi's height eric's
is going to be less than that because he
is shorter
so it would be all of the values that
are to the left of let me do this in
another color
that are less than that
just like that let's do another example
here we are told that sydney wears
skirts when the temperature is warmer
than 25 degrees celsius
write an inequality that describes
t the temperatures at which sydney wears
skirts so again pause this video and see
if you can have a go at
that all right
so when does sydney wear skirts when the
temperature is warmer
than 25 degrees celsius now warmer means
that the temperature is higher than 25
degrees celsius or that the temperature
is greater than 25 degrees celsius and
we're using capital t to denote
temperature
so
we would say capital t this needs to be
higher than 25 degrees or greater than
25
degrees
celsius so t is greater than 25.
let's do one last example here
so here we are told
that lola and haley are running a race
lola finishes the race in 53 seconds
haley finishes
after lola
write an inequality that represents h
haley's finish time in seconds pause the
video and see if you can think about
this
all right so how does haley compare to
lola haley finishes after lola so what
does that mean about haley's time well
that means that haley is going to take
more time than lola to finish the race
so whatever lola's time is
hayley's time is going to be longer or
more or greater than so haley's time is
going to be greater than lola's time
which is 53 seconds because haley
finishes after